es ist giftig skeptiker in den usa auf
dem land in tennessee scheint man sich
einig lass dich vom doktor im himmel
beraten
fast nirgends wird so wenig geimpft wie
hier
ich persönlich will nicht das
versuchskaninchen sein impfstoff liegt
ungenutzt in den apotheken
heute ist niemand gekommen und doch
kämpfen auch hier menschen darum andere
aufzuklären willkommen wir sprechen
heute darüber wie wichtig es ist sich
impfen zu lassen
herdenimmunität das ist das große ziel
der us regierung
doch wie realistisch ist das vor allem
im tief religiösen und republikanischen
süden des landes
dieser mann verschreibt gegen korona in
den kräuter und lebensmittelladen von
walt groß kommen viele menschen wenn es
ihnen nicht gut geht
eine kundin hat mich angerufen und sie
hat mir gesagt ich glaube ich sterbe ich
sagte hey was ist das problem
sie meinte sie können nicht atmen da
habe ich ihr gesagt hol dir wohl kraut
daraus kannst du dir einen tee machen
dann habe ich sie am nächsten morgen
wieder angerufen und sie sagte ich kann
wieder atmen es ist viel besser geworden
wir sind am fuße der appalachen im
norden von tennessee die nächste größere
stadt ist über eine autostunde entfernt
im kleinen kräuter laden trifft sich die
nachbarschaft walt cross ist gegen
masken und gegen impfungen ein gutes
immunsystem oder eine gesunde ernährung
das helfe gegen korona die menschen hier
vertrauen volt cross und wollt cross
vertraut auf gott
ich rate den leuten zu bieten sie sollen
gott fragen was zu tun ist gott ist
mächtig und wenn du bist und der heilige
geist rät er sich impfen zu lassen dann
lass dich impfen wenn er die arbeit ist
zu lassen dann lass es aber lass dich
vom doktor im himmel beraten
die meisten hier kaufen seit jahren bei
ihm ein und die meisten wollen sich
nicht impfen lassen ich glaube jeder
sollte das für sich selbst entscheiden
die die es nehmen wollen können das tun
man weiß so wenig über die
nebenwirkungen
ich bin 34 jahre alt deswegen habe ich
kein hohes risiko zu erkranken
ich verstehe die gründe das möglich
impfen zu lassen
aber ich persönlich will nicht das
versuchskaninchen sein für wort cross
und seine kunden ist klar niemand soll
ihnen hier ratschläge geben vor allem
nicht die demokraten die für ihn alle
sozialisten sind wir erheben uns und
machen klar sagt uns nicht was wir tun
sollen
wir sind frei in amerika wenn ihr
sozialisten sein wollt geht woanders hin
aber macht mich nicht zum sozialisten
und die leute hier widersetzen sich weil
sie stark und frei sein wollen
tennessee republikanisch weiß und tief
religiös auf 15.000 einwohner kommen
hier 100 kirchen 80 prozent haben
vergangenes jahr donald trump gewählt
die impfquote liegt deutlich unter dem
us durchschnitt im alten rom am
stadtrand trifft sich greenville zu bier
baseball und bürger als wir hier das
thema impfen ansprechen wird es
emotional totaler bullshit
warum denken sie dass das ist doch gift
das sie dir in deinen körper spruch sie
müssten mich dafür schon festhalten mich
kann keiner zwingen lieber gehe ich ins
gefängnis bevor ich mich impfen lassen
ich brauche mehr zeit aber meine eltern
sie haben es bekommen sie sehen etwas
älter und das sind die leute die geimpft
werden müssen
was da drin ist kümmert mich nicht
besser als dieses zeug corona zu
bekommen als erstes waren wir absolut
dagegen wir wollten uns nicht impfen
lassen aber dann hat das virus meine
familie erwischt
also haben wir uns unentschieden und
haben uns die impfung geholt wenn murphy
ist bereits geimpft er betreibt die bahn
nebenbei hauptberuflich ist der lehrer
an der high school in greenville er
bekommt die diskussionen in der kneipe
jeden tag mit sich einmischen oder gar
bekehren will er aber niemanden
für mich ist das eine persönliche
entscheidung die leute können sich
impfen lassen oder eben nicht wenn man
das macht und etwas schlimmes passiert
nun ja du wolltest es so wenn man sich
nicht impfen lässt und etwas schlimmes
passiert auch dein ding
es sind unsere entscheidungen dieses
land respektiert das persönliche
entscheidungen führen zu persönlichen
konsequenzen und jede entscheidung die
du triffst hat konsequenzen ich hoffe
die leute verstehen dass das thema
impfen wird im all time highs diskutiert
was sie hier allerdings eint ist die
ablehnung der beiden regierung in
washington unter ein prinzipiell das
misstrauen gegen alles was von dort
kommt
auf einem hügel nicht weit entfernt
steht die kirche der freeware
baptistengemeinde erst seit kurzem
empfängt prediger billy bragg die
menschen wieder persönlich zum
gottesdienst ein jahr hat er den nur
online abhalten können
doch auch in seiner gemeinde sind viele
skeptisch ich würde es nicht nehmen
ausser sie zwingen mich bei der arbeit
warum nicht ich habe angst zu sterben
ich mag impfungen nicht jedes mal wenn
ich mich impfen lassen bekomme ich das
virus zb bei der grippeimpfung da
bekomme ich immer die grippe ich weiß
auch nichts über nebenwirkungen
ich versuche ihnen die ängste zu nehmen
die menschen hören alles mögliche zum
beispiel dass ihnen ein chip
eingepflanzt wird
sie sagen damit die regierung sie
verfolgen und orten kann
ich sage ihnen die regierung könnte euch
doch jetzt schon orten wenn sie das
wirklich wollte und zwar mit einem handy
barry grey ist die person um die sich
hier alles dreht ein mentor eine eminenz
die menschen vertrauen ihm
er hat sich impfen lassen doch andere
vom impfen überzeugen selbst ein vorbild
sein das will er nicht versuchen sie die
leute zu einem warum nicht das sind
alles erwachsene menschen
ich habe versucht gerüchte wie die von
den chips zu zerstreuen
aber meine enkelin zum beispiel sie
heiratet kommenden samstag und hat sich
noch nicht impfen lassen
sie arbeitet in der
öffentlichkeitsarbeit und ihr
arbeitgeber sagt sie soll es machen
sonst verliert sie ihren job
und so singen sie gemeinsam in der
freeware baptistengemeinde die geimpften
und die nicht geimpften die mit maske
und die ohne jeder auf seine weise die
herdenimmunität jedenfalls hier scheint
sie fast unerreichbar
das merken sie auch in call of pharmacy
seit 90 jahren eine institution in
greenville hier könnte man sich impfen
lassen
doch heute haben sie keine kundschaft er
ist aber zählt uns dass sie letzte woche
nur 20 dosen verimpft hat und zeigt uns
dann dass sie eigentlich viel mehr
impfstoff hätte was ist das das sind
zwei kartons mit moderner impfstoff da
sind zehn ampullen mit jeweils zehn
dosen drin
insgesamt 200 dosen heute ist niemand
gekommen und wir haben auch keine
gebuchten termine aber wenn jemand
kommen würde hätten wir sogar noch 40
weitere dosen im kühlschrank wenn wir
die rausholen können wir sie nach 30
minuten sofort verdampfen 240 dosen
corona impfstoff doch niemand will sich
impfen lassen
das was wir im kleinen greenville
erleben sieht man zurzeit überall in den
usa die impf geschwindigkeit geht massiv
zurück der grund so den 19 prozent im
verweigern kommen 15 prozent die noch
zögern skeptisch sind ein problem für
die us regierung die eigentlich gerade
ein neues ziel ausgegeben hat bis zum 14
juli wollen wir 70 prozent der
erwachsenen mit zumindest einer dose
versorgt haben 160 millionen amerikaner
sollen vollständig geimpft sein
ein ehrgeiziges ziel zu geizig joe biden
traf sich deswegen diese woche mit acht
gouverneur
neben der zulassung des bei und tech
impfstoffs für jugendliche im alter von
zwölf bis 15 jahren ging es vor allem um
die nachlassende impf geschwindigkeit
der nicht nur weiße republikaner zögern
auch bei latinos und schwarzen stockt
die impfkampagne
die regierung will jetzt noch mehr in
die communitys gehen aufklären und vor
ort impfen
wichtig sei jetzt dass man sich zeit
nehmen für die menschen sagen experten
wenn man den diesen menschen raum gibt
auch ihre ihrer falschen vorstellung zu
erzählen und wenn man ihnen die die
möglichkeit gibt für ein gespräch in dem
man erst mal zuhört und dann vielleicht
sachen aufklärt dass auch sehr sehr
viele von denen insbesondere
konservativen in den usa die oft solche
solche falschen dinge glauben dass sie
dann ihre meinung ändern und auch sich
impfen lassen
darum kümmern sich leute wie er zurück
in greenville bei doktor vier hensley
hier geboren und aufgewachsen
unermüdlich kämpft der arzt darum die
menschen über die korona impfung
aufzuklären willkommen wir sprechen
heute darüber wie wichtig es ist sich
impfen zu lassen
vier hensley beantwortet jeden tag
fragen der community online bei facebook
und offline im krankenhaus in grün welt
in tennessee wollen die leute nicht
gesagt bekommen was sie zu tun haben je
mehr man sie drängt desto weiter
entfernt sie sich und so redet er
herzlich fiel in diesen tagen und beißt
oft genug auf granit ich finde dass das
mit der impfung sehr schnell ging
ich bin mir nicht sicher ob sie so viel
daran geforscht haben wie ich mir das
wünschen würde
doch manchmal schafft er es den menschen
die ängste zu nehmen
karin hübner war sich bisher unsicher
hatte angst davor sich impfen zu lassen
ich habe noch keine impfung
ich wollte erst mit ihm reden und sehen
was er darüber denkt okay aber du
vertraust mir ja warum vertraust du mir
weil du mir schon oft geholfen hast zehn
minuten nimmt sich für hensley zeit
carron alles in ruhe zu erklären werden
sie sich jetzt impfen lassen
ja ich hatte mich impfen lassen ja super
ich mache hier einen kleinen instanz
danke ich werde es mir holen
doktor für hensley kämpft weiter jeden
tag sagt er
bis alle geimpft und damit außer gefahr
sind hier in seiner heimat in greenville
tennessee